pour prévenir le monde de demain
il me semble qu'ils font d'abord
incapable de comprendre le monde
d'aujourd'hui de pouvoir étudier jeudi à
prédire son évolution
pourquoi ne pas le faire avec
l'intelligence artificielle en effet
c'est une approche qui est assez
prometteuse
je vais essayer de vous pour un de ceux
là aujourd'hui on cherche à comprendre
la dynamique des six semaines par
exemple white udine un tabou politique
sur mon entreprise une économie une
société par exemple
peut-être que vous avez beau but mais
pour faire baisser le chômage la
pollution
où est le palais discutant d'un monde
virtuel où vous pourrez l'expérimenté
sans danger sans risque en faire berner
tous les paramètres et on y est c'est
fait cet incident de la simulation
médias jean mon domaine de recherche que
jamais à vous faire découvrir
aujourd'hui
alors il essaie de faire avec une
méthode scientifique qui a fait ses
preuves
vous connaissez sans doute on observe un
phénomène on recolle du monné dessus
ensuite on fait un modèle plus ou moins
formalisées avec langage naturel du
baptême active ou des ados ride on
simule ce modèle sur ordinateur pour
voir ce qui se passe
l'argile l'analogie en scène de
l'astrolabe ici que lorsque le système
qu'on voulait étudier et composée
d'êtres humains ça se complique
fortement au roi parce que un être
humain
chacune et chacun sait déjà un système
complexe c'est à dire composé d'entités
de nombreuses entités en interaction
anciens tous vos neurones à tous les
processus physico chimiques qui sont
actuellement dans votre corps vous
m'écoutez et en plus un être humain
c'est imprévisible
par exemple est-ce que vous êtes capable
de dire
je vais dire on les prochaines souvent
d'aplomb donc ça c'est déjà compliqué un
seul être mais imaginez maintenant mais
plusieurs
pourrait-on dire une société donc c'est
très difficile d'étudier les
comportements humains
mais comme je suis et résiste le mans a
tiré par la difficulté j'ai décidé de
consacrer ma vie peut-être d'ailleurs
des 10 ans de la carrière en face à ce
point d'eau propre
alors bon comment comment on voit là en
métaux l'intelligence artificielle mais
d'abord c'est quoi l'intelligence
artificielle historiquement il s'agit de
construire des machines fin dit
intelligent dans la mesure où elles sont
capables bien d'agir avec laurent et
rock band the et dessiné et peint défi
mais la façon dont alphonse cela peut
s'inspirer directement dessus que nous
montre une infusion ou peu vive
intelligence artificielle on m'a dit il
ya fait recours vous connaissez
peut-être je sais pas dit blue howatson
ol fagots eh bien ces systèmes ils
jouent respectivement échec à jeopardy
ou au bo une façon très différente
le nom et les mains le faisons par
exemple ils utilisent des systèmes
n'accroche ont validé la mesure où déjà
ses six tellement joué contre eux des
mines au froid pour l'élite sociale à la
chine est à son temps à me la jouer cool
très belle et puis également qu'ils vont
générer des quantités gigantesques de
solutions possibles pour choisir la
meilleure à la renault êtres humains
nous avons une approche beaucoup plus
synthétique
nous allons effectuer des raccourcis en
plus les systèmes le bila qui n'utilise
ce qu'on appelle des réseaux de neurones
artificiels vous avais dit roland temps
de parler à l'apprentissage automatique
ni pleurer c'est à dire donc ce sont des
raisons tomates qui crèvent dernier
signant d'entrée
appliquons course ou mathématiques et on
voit un signal de sortie à dr au bon
système ils vont venir ce sont des
boîtes noires
rien que ça marche mais on sait pas très
bien pourquoi et comment ce sont un des
systèmes qui ne sont pas très explicable
mais l'interprète
seulement il ya une autre façon
d'étudier les comportements in america
ça consiste
on le voit derrière moi à offrir la
boîte à la paix ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur le pet les bonnes pensées
une mauvaise pensée comment nous allons
représenter le monde
est ce que ce sont les concepts des
images de la musique
comment nous allons étudier et
d'utiliser ces représentations pour agir
sur ce monde et quel serait l'impact les
émotions de nos affaires et puis c'est
pas terminé parce que l'être humain est
profondément social on interagit avec
son voisin ne serait ce que pour
l'anglais pour finir qu'on n'est pas
content on interagit avec la
communication langage et puis y'a plein
de stands qui sont d'ailleurs
passionnante à hêvié l'interaction
sociale
quand on est phénomène de migration les
opinions et rumeurs mais phénomène de
mimétisme qui font qu'un moment donné on
a envie de porter les mêmes vêtements
que quelqu'un qu'elle croise dans la rue
et quand vous savez ces phénomènes sont
amplifiées maintenant avec le
développement des réseaux sociaux
donc c'est assez compliqué il va falloir
tenir compte tout cela mais alors j'ai
une bonne mais je suis aussi pour
positiver philosophie positive
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il ya une
solution pour étudier cela et donc on
l'a fait pour vous ça s'appelle un
système multi âges
alors c est apparu dans les années 90
dans les électrovannes et ça s'appelle
intelligence artificielle 10 plus est
est comme son nom l'indiqué un petit peu
ces composés des changements
informatiques qui sont inclus alors
voici par exemple un schéma qui illustre
ce système donc vous avez des agents
dont un agenda c'est autonome si
proactif dire que ça décide quand il au
delà jour mbj sa ces objets
propre ses compétences et ressources ça
représente son environnement sa
interagir avec son environnement et avec
les autres alors vous savez peut-être
pas mais vous les connaissez ces
systèmes vous avez déjà vu notamment si
vous regardez une série célèbre en haut
à gauche il ya maintenant lorsque vous
avez par exemple dans un film dans une
série d'e mail combattre main sur un
champ de bataille où des milliers de
spectateurs enfin stable en fait un
système de sièges en plus des figurants
si aussi appliqué à phynances transport
à la coordination de robots de gros et
cetera
alors maintenant la question c'est
comment on va pouvoir appliquer cela sur
des comportements et là je vais prendre
un petit vin
regardons ce qui s'affiche derrière moi
c'est une carte qui représentent la
population abords de la ville chicago et
à la lame est frustrant tout ça aux
états unis ça ne vous aura pas échappé
et il ya une couleur et la couleur et un
ami à l'origine de cette population ça
peut être d'origine caucasienne
afro-américaine espagne et asiatiques
etc
alors il faut qu'il vous fera passer de
ses membres leur sont relativement ni fo
rtement il n'y a pas de mélanges de la
population la panne coxyde et sociale ce
qui pose plein de problèmes sociétaux
alors ça c'est pas seulement aux états
unis on le retrouve dans la plupart les
conduit leurs travers le monde a
expliqué sa première hypothèse vous avez
ça m'arrive parfois une vision
pessimiste de l'humanité est menée par
allégeance au racisme alors si vous
l'être humain est profondément raciste
email par ses semblables première est
bien la deuxième bonne nouvelle on mari
pour l'instant
il ya deux bonnes nouvelles la troisième
c est un vrai conflit l'enseigné
recherche
ce sera encore mieux donc la deuxième
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il est possible
de trouver une explication alors que les
gens ne serait éventuellement pas
raciste oui et ça c'est grâce notamment
à la simulation lui tiennent bien sûr et
aussi un mode est très astucieux de
monsieur dans la chimie sur nos machines
en 1971 c'est un économiste
il a proposé un petit modèle sain que je
mène en boucle il est bon il faut savoir
que plus tard d'ailleurs cette langue
orale prix nobel d'économie en doctorat
le modèle suivant imaginons que chacune
et chacun ici présents d'ailleurs vous
aider individuellement un seuil de
tolérance
c'est à dire une proportion de gens que
vous soyez vous souhaitez avoir autres
autour de vous ils soient semblables
par exemple vous souhaitez que là où
vous habitez pour qu'ils ont moins d'un
pour cent de gens qui est la même
origine ou le même niveau de revenu ou
la verrerie nos politiques ont pas la
même religion etc
si ce seuil de satisfaction n'est pas
minime a pas satisfait à ce moment-là
vous déménagiez jusqu'à ce que vous
trouviez un endroit où le seul devient
satisfaits alors ce qui modère c'est
simple peut très bien sous programmés et
on veut le simuler avec un système où
siège alors par exemple ça va donner des
configurations suivante alors on a
simplifié en disant qu'il ya deux types
d'agents manière ya des rouges et ppr
pourrait dire pour l'instant nous tous
ont même seul alors moyennement gbagbo
vous avez une situation en guinée c'est
à dire où la plupart des gens sont
satisfaits ou on a relativement mieux
entre les jours en revanche droite d'une
civilisation total
vous avez devant les ondes et verts qui
sa fille mais l'intérêt ça va plus loin
et c'est un de la découverte majeure de
ce modèle c'est qu'en fait au final on
obtient une similarité donc une série
gassion beaucoup plus fortes secousses
un minimum en voulait au départ par
exemple on pourrait voir ce petit
tableau
si vous l'avez recèle de 20% des réseaux
mais un peu ce côté g 20 pour cent de
gens comme vous mais au final si tout le
monde fait ça par l'interaction sociale
on se retrouve avec un seul décès
inactif de plus de 60 courses et comme
on le voit sur cette courbe ici ça monte
très vite à 50% seul déjà à 81% tri
nations et ramène en arrive à sa course
c'est pour cela que je disais n'est pas
nécessaire d'apparat si ce n'est d'avoir
un seuil de tolérance très élevé pour
générer au final on célébration et ça ça
émergent grâce à la simulation mehdi la
jambe et c'est pour ça c'est suspectes
sont intéressants pour faire émerger des
jo d'un haut niveau que le ce1 ont
fortement un milieu alors c'est un
modèle évidemment très simple mais il a
conduit ensuite tout un courant de
recherche sur la dynamique urbaine et
moi j'avoue que en tant que chercheur
ce qui nous motive c'est dé ce type
d'attaqué des problèmes sociétaux
important donc l'avenir l'aubaine bien
sûr l'écologie et l'environnement il ya
aussi la santé au travail les problèmes
de transports ou les problèmes de
diffusion d'innovations et bien le
marché du travail sur lequel j'ai dû
travailler justement bon voulu essayer
de cette formule contre le chômage ou la
parité tout essayé bon c'est vrai que
malheureusement le chômage au monde au
pays ou que la france a du mal à baisser
on a un chômage structurel qui a été
assez important est ce qu'on peut faire
pour expliquer tout cela avec un
économiste gérard à l'eau et un
informaticien en ligue 2 qui a fait la
thèse sur ce sujet nous avons construit
le simulateur occident inspirateur nous
envoûter dix agents qui actuellement le
modèle déjà j'en ai plus
sur un marché du travail on ça
fonctionne d'abord il ya des agents qui
vont représenter en vous et moi des
individus alors ces individus ils sont
vingt certaines étapes il serait en
train de travailler
il doit être en train de travailler mais
bon on chercher un autre job ils peuvent
être chemin
il leur est inactif ce qui signifie
qu'elles ont renoncé à chercher du
travail
voilà ce qui peut être certains d'entre
vous imagine les étudiants alors de
l'autre côté vous avez les agents qui
vont représenter les entreprises
ces entreprises de conduite un bien dont
la demande varie au cours du temps et un
moment donné la balle à la demande elle
peut augmenter ou baisser mais l
infanterie saga 3 mois recule c'est
parce qu'avec seulement mais si elle
commence à voir de la demande qui
augmente mort à l'économie sans d'arthur
si l'entreprise va dire que je vais
devoir créer des potes pour satisfaire
cette demande donc à décider si a créé
un cdd au cdi
à ce moment là comme ça se passe dans la
baie elle va alors j'espère pouvoir
qu'elle va poster sur un site internet
et puis ceux qui cherchent du boulot ils
ont 6 posté les candidates eu des gens
plus ou moins tout cas elle aussi et
puis il y aura des vêtements tout
simplement
ça s'arrête pas là parce que le marché
du travail
il est dans un environnement politique
du juridique assez important et donc
dans boxing day aussi connais notre
partie du code du travail et aussi tous
les décrets et ordonnances qui ont plus
où je lui à chaque fois qu'un
gouvernement à richard lambert chaque
fois on change mon fils est par exemple
au niveau du semis ou des allocations
chômage les conditions des sentiments
est donc voila un petit peu comment
commence à sa fonctionne et alors on a
une simulation qui va se dérouler dans
le temps si le cycle au guépard
n'initialise de systèmes à l'échelle du
marché real actuellement et sous les
chênes
gecas entière et 1,2 milliard ça
représente vous donner une idée entre
20000 et 30000 agents informatif et puis
ensuite également l'installation des
rôles creux comme ça se passe d'un monde
du travail les entreprises comme j'ai
dit qu'elle décide de créer des preuves
pouvant détruire
elle gère les évaluer les employés et
donc devant malheureusement elles font
faillite ou à des licenciements
les rend les individus mais eux ils sont
dans un état il suivi parce que je suis
bien dans l'eau n'est pas parce qu
apparemment très pas compte que je serai
plus satisfait par exemple je suis
étudiant on va peut-être que j'ai décidé
à rentrer sur le marché du travail est
arrêté mes études je suis chauvin a
peut-être que je me décourage pas ce que
je trouve pas de bloquer ce moment là
tout devient inactif donc tout ça est
internalisé dans aussi il ya des
candidatures comme je les guide au
traitement des promotions ils vivent
bien beau d'une démographie
parce que les individus sont rencontrés
ou les ménages donc l'ambition d'aider
les célibataires vous avez des gens se
sont mariés pour les enfants quant à
l'enfant donc d'en signer dans mon mari
les agents ont une fille divorcée et on
gère des naissances et laissez nous le
mot des cimes ouvriers bon alors à quoi
ça sert tout ça et là nous qui nous
intéresse nous motive c'est malgré tout
les glo petit public et puis s'il en
trouvait damon fille si possible pour
essayer d'améliorer l'emploi bon il a
testé à peu près tout
et pour vous montrer un petit peu ce
qu'on peut faire je vais revenir sur la
dernière d'entre accélère la loi travail
coct ans vous n'avez entendu un peu par
les miens printemps 2016 mais bon si
longtemps ça a fait couler beaucoup
d'encre ça les autonomies se sont
opposés ça a mis des milliers de gens
dans la rue certains d'entre vous
étaient dans la rue parce que c'est le
point qui est vraiment ce qui inquiète
ex depuis un article qui est
actuellement le numéro 67 et apprécié
cet article qui facilite les
licenciements économiques
cette année l'entreprise laporte moment
et elle demande ou un chiffre d'affaires
tout laissait pouvait procéder sans
autre justification à les licenciements
économiques
alors on a décidé
de signer cet article et ainsi on a été
les premiers et à ce jour et seule à
proposer et l'évaluation quantitative de
la loi parce que au ministère notamment
on n'avait pas fait d'évaluation
quantitatifs avant de lancer la broye
alors ça vous fait d'abord été un
pionnier a marqué ses anneaux a permis l
aux besoins ciblés par le fbi et aussi
leur dans l'épreuve les électeurs de
cette fois non j'imagine ce qui nous
intéresse d'accès résultat alors ce qui
est sûr c'est que a priori cette web a
profondément bouleversé le marché du
travail
mais là il est ce que vous avez pas
financer les recherches les nouvelles
mais les mauvaises mauvaise nouvelle
c'est que ça ne leur parle pour la trêve
les études bout de quatre ans le chômage
ne baisse pas en espace le cdi deuxième
contrat majoritairement beau
actuellement 60 81% des vendanges sont
en cdd
mais avec le nouveau roubaix loi 70% ce
français né mais le cellier de viande de
phoque le court est plus précaire et
disent qu'il ya aussi un autre phénomène
une personne a récemment prédit c'est
que la loi est favorable aux jeunes
c'est bizarre ce que c'est ce qu'ils ont
manifestée n'est a priori le chemin des
jeunes de l'année ces deux cent
cinquante mille parce que les jeunes
bénéficient de l'augmentation des cds en
revanche ça se fait au détriment des
plus de 50 ans qui eux n'ont pas de
bénéfices et subissent de plein fouet
l'augmentation des licenciements vous
avez quelque chose de plus quelques 50
ans donc si on schématise grossièrement
c'est comme si les jeunes on voit ici
preniez le boulot de l'eau par ah bon
alors évidemment ces résultats sont en
france avec des préventions comme tout
modèle mis en pense que ces résultats
sont tout juste pour ça qu'elle épingle
à linge mouillé tease et la sphère
n'avait cessé d'alerter les citoyens et
politiques
bon soyons honnêtes on a eu plus de
succès auprès des citoyens eux des
politiques mais bon ça c'est un autre
problème
en tout cas envie de continuer lorsqu'on
pense que c'est
sujet intéressant et par exemple ce
qu'on pourrait faire ces noms dès la 9e
légion artificielle de déterminer par
elle-même en optimisant certains
critères une nouvelle politique de
l'emploi qui voudraient des pistes pour
améliorer les services et chômage ou
alors utiliser pour 6 pour évaluer
l'impact du numérique et notamment de
l'intelligence artificielle sur le
marché du travail se réunissent en ce
moment au débat est-ce que les robots
une machine elle pour faire mais c'est
augmenter l'eau chaude à londres et
celle des villes et c'est un peu
scientifiquement et surtout ce cas
serait rigolo de voir une ia qui ainsi
malgré l'impact des autres villages sur
les bleus en cas pour revenir au sujet
de sept jours je veux pas les décevoir
mais chaque fenêtre je ne sais pas de
quoi demain sera fait mais pamiers ii
qui se tape mon genou même disait
l'avenir ne se privera pas il se prépare
premier prêt pour mieux préparer le
monde de demain je vous propose
d'utiliser les intelligences
artificielles de la simulation est sûre
je rêve mon baboo banques
merlin monde ont touché aux petits
serait généralisée dans tous les
ministères des centres de décision
stratégique de manière à ce qu aucun
projet de loi une nouvelle décision qui
pourrait inciter les n'y ait personne ne
soit testé tout simplement avant d'être
mises en oeuvre
on y toujours utilisé la simulation est
par ailleurs il faudra le faire en un
claque sion avec tous les acteurs
concernés les citoyens dans le cas d'une
aide à la décision participatives ont
fait bien des simulations avant de
lancer des fusées ont suffi pour le fais
pas pour les sociétés ce qui est appelé
société mère et puis essayer la s'ouvre
- c'est maintenant un voyage un chemin
qu'on espérait tirer au coeur de la
complexité des problèmes pour essayer
avec pas la résoudre mais au moins de la
prison et du sous cet angle la
simulation c'est un peu comme le miroir
de nos comportements
alors osons nous confronter à ceux là
haut sont confrontés nos jugements
innovateurs à nos actes et aux
conséquences de ses actes sur les autres
sur la planète
osons cette forme dia espérons qu'elle
nous permette de nemo capian fasse en
toute conscience et en bonne
intelligence pour bercy
[Applaudissements]